pour le mois de septembre comme vous
pouvez voir sur ce planning également on
est on un taux d'occupation aujourd'hui
qui avoisine les 27 28 % sachant qu'on
est le 20 juillet et que normalement à
cette date d'occupation pour septembre
devrait être entre 50 et 55 % donc ça
veut dire qu'on est quasiment deux fois
moins que d'habitude
[Musique]
sachant qu'une grande majorité des gens
qui sont dans ce planning de réservation
sont des gens qui sont en dehors de
l'europe
donc ça veut dire que si jamais il ya
des restrictions sanitaires ou quoi que
ce soit mon planning sur un vide en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les étrangers ne sont pas là
et parie que les principalement des
étrangers
or sans ces gens là ne pouvons pas vivre
ça fait 18 mois que nous ne faisons plus
de chiffre d'affaires donc si le
gouvernement ne met pas en place des
aides pour nous aider à passer ce cap
nous ne pourrons pas survivre et nous
nous pourrons les hôtels indépendants
vont disparaître à partir des puits tout
l'hôtel a fermement affirmé nous avons
tout fait pour éviter cela mais
malheureusement faute de demande
comme j'ai pu le voir sur les plannings
nous sommes obligés de fermer à partir
de 8 août pour une durée indéterminée